Я вітаю вас. Мене звати Елла Василівна.
Я вчитель історії спеціалізованої
школи №250 міста Києва.
Познайомилися. Отже, запрошую
вас на урок історії України до 8 класу.
Пропоную розпочати урок. Чи є у
вас під рукою зошит, ручка і олівці?
Отож, звернути увагу на дошку
- тема сьогоднішнього уроку.
Для того, щоб краще
зрозуміти сьогоднішній матеріал,
щоб все запам'ятати і справитися
з найскладнішими завданнями,
я пропоную трішечки
повернутися назад в історію.
Пригадати деякі дуже важливі факти,
які допоможуть нам розібратися
з сьогоднішнього темою.
Давайте спробуємо пригадати
першу дату - 1686 рік. Пам’ятаєте?
6 травня 1686 року до Москви
приїздить польська делегація.
Вона представляє
інтереси польського короля,
зустрічається з делегацією, які
представляють інтереси московського царя
і ведуть перемовини про
облаштування українських земель.
Підписується «Трактат про вічний мир».
Доволі пафосна назва. Чи не так?
Річ у тому, що цей
договір був не випадковим.
Протягом останніх півтораста років між
Річчю Посполитою і Московським царством
дуже часто йшли збройні
конфлікти, більші або менші,
навіть цілі війни за оволодіння
спадщиною Київської Русі.
Землі переходили з рук в руки,
дуже часто царі та королі воювали,
мирилися, підписувати договори.
Один з найбільших таких серйозних
договорів - це Андрусівське перемир'я.
Підписане було 1667
році і вирішувало долю
Правобережної України
і Лівобережної України.
Але перемир'я, самі розумієте, - лише
перемир'я. До великого миру було далеко.
Проходить час і ось 1686
рік – «Трактат про вічний мир».
Зверніть, будь ласка,
увагу щодо умов трактату.
За Московським царством визнавалася:
Лівобережна Україна – Гетьманщина, Київ,
хоча московському царю довелося заплатити
за Київ біля 146 тисяч золотих рублів,
Запорозька Січ, Смоленщина, Чернігово-
Сіверщина з Черніговом і Стародубом.
А от Річ Посполита зберегла за собою:
північну Київщину, Волинь, Галичину,
притому взяла на себе зобов’язання не
кривдити посполитих християн православних.
Південь Київщини і Брацлавщина
– найбільш розорені території,
мали залишатися безлюдними і нейтральними.
Зверніть увагу, що Поділля ще якийсь
час залишалося за Османською імперією.
Особливим пунктом у «вічному» договорі
писалося, що сторони, які його підписали
домовлялися про спільну боротьбу проти
Османської імперії та Кримського ханства.
Знаєте, для однієї та для другої
сторони це дуже був вигідний договір.
Річ у тім, що московські
царі мріяли збільшити
кордони своєї держави,
а крім того вийти до морів.
Перше, на що звернули увагу
московські царі - узбережжя Чорного моря.
Але там стояло Кримське ханство,
далі Османська імперія -
опора Кримського ханства.
Через те, щоб розпочати
війну на півдні, треба
було захистити як можна
надійніше західні кордони.
«Вічний мир» є як раз тим захистом.
Більше того, Московське царство отримало
допомогу ще з боку польського короля.
Прикро сказати тільки одне, що у
той час, коли у Москві йшли перемовини
і укладалися статті «Вічного миру»,
на цю нараду не покликали
гетьмана Івана Самойловича.
Йому, здається, навіть і не повідомили
та й не вважали за потрібне це робити.
Коли Самойлович дізнався
про підписання «Вічного миру»
він, кажуть, був страшенно розлючений. Він
вважав, що це зрада інтересів Гетьманщини.
Але що може зробити васал,
коли так вирішив сюзерен.
І ось настає 1687 рік.
Московські царі приймають рішення,
що не треба відкладати в далекий ящик
завдання звоювати Крим хоча б,
пробитися до Чорного моря і готують
перший Кримський похід.
Оскільки в той час на престолі
знаходиться два малолітні царі:
цар Іван і його молодший син цар Петро,
а фавориткою є 24-річна
принцеса-царівна Софія,
- самі розумієте, в похід немає йти кому.
Через те Софія призначає
головнокомандувачем
цього першого Кримського походу свого
фаворита Василя Васильовича Голіцина.
Ви бачите його на дошці
але Голіцин зразу ставить умову,
він вирушає в далекий похід, бере з собою
чи то 100, чи то 150 тисяч війська,
але без козаків йому не справитися.
І тоді козакам і гетьману Самойловичу
нагадують про те, що вони мають
зобов'язання перед московськими царями
допомагати їм у всіх військових баталіях.
Через те Самойлович мусить
приєднатися до війська Голіцина
і надати вояків не менше чим 50 тисяч.
Починається похід, але з
самого початку все пішло не так.
Річ у тім, що не було єдності в
об'єднаному козацько-московському війську,
а татари - вони дуже добре підготувалися.
Як тільки вони дізналися про те, що
підходить військо московське і козацьке,
перше що вони зробили - запалили степ.
Степ почав горіти, димова
завіса - це серйозна перешкода,
це пряма небезпека просування
вперед і, чесно кажучи, як кажуть росіяни:
«несолоно хлебавши» військо
починає повертатися назад.
Але виникає питання, як пояснити у
Москві причини такого невдалого походу.
І тут ще одна прикрість.
Річ у тім, що козацька
старшина не завжди помірковано
вела себе по відношенню
до своїх гетьманів.
З різних причин, але
дуже часто на стіл царям
лягали різні доноси,
різні пасквільні листи,
як казали, не обминула
ця доля і Самойловича.
Як раз в саме цей час на стіл Голіцину
лягає чергова скарга-донос на Самойловича.
Що начебто він зрадник, що це по його
вині так все склалося невдало з походом.
Цим, звичайно, скористався Голіцин.
Він відсилає листа до Москви і повідомляє,
що він звичайно виграв би в цьому бою,
але вся справа в козаках.
Самойлович, начебто, не виявив належної
старанності, Самойлович, можливо,
повідомив і попередив кримських
татарів, можливо, можливо, можливо.
Але як би там не було,
сталося те, що сталося.
Відповідь з Москви не
примусила себе довго чекати
і прийшов твердий і однозначний наказ.
Івана Самойловича – зрадника і вора
заарештувати і позбавити гетьманства.
Але ми повертаємося до
козацько-московського війська.
Гетьмана усунули від влади, похід
провалився, але життя не зупиняється.
І поки що повністю
розправитися з козацтвом,
розправитися з Гетьманщиною
московські царі не мають ніякої сили.
Тоді вони приймають рішення
обрати іншого гетьмана.
Якщо можете, запишіть цю дату,
тому що, власне цим ми переходимо
до вивчення нашого
сьогоднішнього матеріалу.
25 липня 1687 року - початок
гетьманування Івана Мазепи.
Для того, щоб краще
зрозуміти хто був цей чоловік,
чому його вважають непересічною
особистістю, видатним політиком,
я пропоную переглянути декілька
хвилин навчального фільму.
Він об’єднав Лівобережну
і Правобережну Україну.
Будував заклади освіти
та видавав літературу.
Закладав та відновлював
церкви і монастирі.
Він повстав за волю України, став
європейським символом волелюбного духу.
Надихав художників, письменників,
поетів, композиторів по всьому світу.
Про нього знімали фільми. Його
ім’ям названі міста в різних країнах.
Гетьман Іван Мазепа –
герой світового масштабу.
Ви знаєте, по різному розповідають
історію як обирали Мазепу.
Я пропоную вам спогади
написані шотландським генералом,
який служив у російській
армії, він був свідком тих подій.
І дивіться, що він написав. Спробуйте
прочитати або послухайте, як буде зручно.
Текст на екрані
Ситуація складалася таким чином,
що вже не один рік і не один раз козаки,
підписавши угоду в 1654 році,
мусили обирати гетьмана тільки з
дозволу московських царів.
Так ось, Голіцин зажадав,
щоб вони зробили рішення.
Спочатку запанувала тиша,
але згодом почулися голоси,
що хочуть Мазепу на гетьмана.
Івана, кричали в одній
стороні, Івана - в другій.
То голосніше, то тихіше, але все
дружніше, дружніше - Івана Мазепу.
Після того на лавку став думний
дяк і голосно прочитав текст присяги.
Рівночасно принесли книжку зі статтями.
Про які статті йде мова, пам’ятаєте?
Кожен гетьман, який
отримував гетьманську булаву,
повинен був перепідписати черговий
новий договір з московським царем.
Виникло питання, а чому Мазепа?
Чесно кажучи, Мазепа був не один
претендент на гетьманську булаву.
Були, як мінімум, ще три претендента.
Але так сталося, що Мазепа
задовольняв своїми якостями
і московських царів, перш за все.
Наступне, Мазепа
задовольняв козацьку старшину,
яка все більше прагнула до
елітарності, до аристократизму
і Мазепа, в принципі,
підтримував їхні бажання.
Але Мазепа подобався козакам
і простим селянам-посполитим.
Всі говорили про Мазепу, що він
такий сильний, твердий у своїх рішеннях
рішеннях і, можливо, йому
вдасться навести порядок в Україні.
Зверніть увагу, як про Мазепу писав
французьких посол Жан де Балюз.
Текст на екрані
Отже, Іван Мазепа.
Але Іван Мазепа того ж 1687 року мусив
підписати угоду з московським царем,
тобто статті, які ввійшли в
історію як «Коломацькі статті».
Я би хотіла, щоб ми зараз
виконали невеличку практичну роботу.
Я підготувала урок свій таким
чином, щоб ми могли порівнювати.
Подивіться, верхня частина
виділена іншим кольором -
це статті з угоди, які писав
ще Богдан Хмельницький.
Пам'ятаєте, «Березневі статті».
А нижче це фрагмент «Коломацьких статтів».
Отже, перше на що ми звертаємо увагу.
За Богдана Хмельницького козаки
мали право самостійно обирати і усувати
Гетьмана та старшину.
При цьому, українська старшина
та суд залишалися самостійними
і не підпорядковувалися Москві.
Старшині заборонялося без дозволу
його Величності обирати гетьмана,
але і гетьман не мав права
впливати на козацьку старшину.
Ви розумієте, в яких складних
умовах опинився Іван Мазепа.
Йому приходилося керувати
Гетьманщиною, не знаючи
наскільки він може обпертися
на козацьку старшину.
Бо і козацька старшина
не знала, а кого їм слухати?
Згідно «Коломацьких статтів» - не
такий вже й сильний український гетьман.
Наступне. Гетьману не заборонялося
приймати чужоземних послів,
але він мусив повідомляти
про мету їхнього приїзду.
Якщо раптом якийсь дипломат був
вороже налаштований до Московського царя,
дозволяв собі якісь крамольний речі,
звичайно такого просто треба було
заарештовувати, як мінімум.
Але тепер подивіться, будь ласка, що
було написано в «Коломацьких статтях».
Гетьману заборонялося підтримувати
самостійні дипломатичні відносини
з усіма державами.
Тобто тільки з дозволу царя.
Особливо вказувалось на
заборону вести торгівлю з Кримом.
У договорі було закріплено зобов'язання
гетьмана направляти свої війська на війни
з Кримським ханством
та Османською імперією.
Чесно кажучи, це дуже серйозна і
дуже критична для козаків умова.
Річ у тім, що козаки часто
воювали з Кримським ханством,
вони ходили на Османську імперію,
але так само козаки часто і
торгували з цими землями.
І у козаків був уже напрацьований
південний напрямок торгівлі.
Це джерело доходів у козаків.
Така заборона серйозно вдарила по
економічній спроможності Гетьманщини.
Раніше московська залога
знаходилася у великих містах.
Звичайно, вона, начебто, допомагала
гетьману захищати Гетьманщину,
а насправді - контролювала козацьке
військо, контролювала гетьмана.
Але такого ще не було, щоб
в самій столиці, в Батурині,
розміщувався пункт московських
стрільців начебто для охорони гетьмана.
Ви вірити в це?
Для контролю за гетьманом
і гетьманською поведінкою.
Для того, щоб зробити
його ручним і слухняним.
Я цю цитату вивела на екран не випадково.
Я б навіть не хотіла б її коментувати.
Я думаю, що ви самі все
зрозумієте і в цьому розберетеся.
«Щоби Малоросію не
називали землею гетьманською,
а лише визнавали землею, яка знаходиться
в царській самодержавній владі».
Тобто бажано, коли говорити про українські
землі, якими тепер управляє Іван Мазепа,
не вживати слово Гетьманщина.
Малоросія, володіння
московських царів, як завгодно,
але навіть відучити
населення від цієї назви.
А там і до знищення Гетьманщини недалеко.
Уявляєте, Мазепа, підписуючи «Коломацькі
статті», розумів, що він гетьман держави,
назву якої не можна навіть називати.
Гетьмана особливо зобов'язували
сприяти російсько-українським шлюбам.
Це мало зміцнити, начебто,
стосунки між московською стороною
і українськими землями,
але ця природна асиміляція
мала дуже далеко ідучі плани.
Об'єднавши в такий спосіб два
народи, українців позбавляли можливості
не те що від’єднатися
колись, а навіть думати про це.
Постало питання спільної
історії, спільної родинної історії.
Московські царі знали, що роблять.
Загалом, вчені ось так визначають роль і
значення, і місце «Коломацьких статей».
Виникає питання, Мазепа отримав
булаву, чи зможе він її утримати?
Чи зможе він управляти державою і
чи є у нього на те здатності відповідні?
І знову вертаємося до французького посла.
Дивіться, що він пише і
будьте уважні, бо в кінці тексту
я вам поставлю невеличке запитання,
на яке ви маєте відповісти,
не дивлячись на текст.
«З Московії поїхав на Україну,
країну козаків, де був кілька днів
гостем володаря Мазепи, що
обіймає найвищу владу в цій країні...
Він вельми полюбляє оздоблювати
свою розмову латинськими цитатами,
а досконалістю знання
цієї мови може суперничати
з найкращими нашими отцями єзуїтами.
Його мова взагалі добірна й
чепурна; щоправда, під час бесіди
більше воліє мовчати та слухати інших.
При його дворі – два лікарі німці, з
якими Мазепа розмовляє їхньою мовою,
а з італійськими майстрами, яких
є кілька у гетьманській резиденції,
говорив по-італійськи.
Я розмовляв із господарем України
польською та латинською мовами…
сам бачив у нього газети
французькі і голландські».
А ось тепер, будь ласка, дивимся
на мене й не дивимся на дошку.
Скількома мовами володів Мазепа?
Пригадуємо.
Перевірити ви себе зможете тоді,
коли повернетеся до цього уроку на
YouTube каналі, але рухаємося далі.
Ви знаєте, коли Мазепа після всіх
церемоній повернувся в свою резиденцію,
він почав думати, а як
йому управляти державою?
Багато істориків каже, що він
дуже швидко встановив діагноз.
Він встановив і визначив найважливіші
проблеми, з якими стикається Гетьманщина
і які треба було негайно подолати. Не в
перший рік свого гетьманування, а пізніше.
Але Іван Мазепа написав дуже
симпатичний поетичний твір.
Він називається «Дума».
Дехто цей твір називає
ще політичною програмою,
така собі коротка політична програма.
Іван Мазепа задумав створити
державу західноєвропейського зразка,
притому зберігши козацькі традиції.
Чесно кажучи, це було надзавдання.
Ви пам'ятаєте і знаєте з Всесвітньої
історії, що в Європі в цей час
абсолютні монархії, притому
доведені до рівня абсолютизму.
А козацтво - це все таки
демократичний устрій.
І як можна було поєднати це, напевно,
бачив і уявляв собі сам Іван Мазепа,
а можливо він був попереду історії,
тому що саме в цей час в Західній Європі
назрівають демократичні революції,
коли стинали голови самим монархам.
Мазепа прийняв рішення і взявся за роботу.
Ми маємо з вами розібратися, що означає
держава західноєвропейського зразка.
Перш за все - це поділ на стани.
Пам'ятаєте, в Західній Європі
суспільство поділялося на три стани
стани і всі три стани були абсолютно
непрозорими, за рідким виключенням.
Пам'ятаєте казку про Попелюшку?
Але, загалом, той, хто народився
селянином, залишалися все життя селянином.
І так його діти, і внуки.
Той, хто народився феодалом,
знатною людиною з привілеями,
він, навіть не маючи гроша за
душею, залишався феодалом.
Перше, що мав зробити Мазепа - це
впорядкувати землеволодіння.
Справа в тому, що починаючи ще з часів
національно-визвольної боротьби 1648 року,
на українських землях з'явилося
дуже багато вільних земельних угідь.
І тут почав діяти принцип Гетьманщини.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу на дошку.
Звичайною мовою кажучи, коли ти бачиш
вільні землі, ти можеш їх займати стільки,
скільки можеш обробити,
і якщо ти їх обробляєш,
то згідно звичаєвого права, ніхто
в тебе ці землі забрати не може.
Справа в тому, що землі розбиралися
і селянами, і міщанами, і старшиною,
притому що старшина прибрала
до своїх рук дуже багато земель.
Після того дуже хитра старшина
починає скуповувати землі,
скуповувати у тих,
хто не міг її обробляти.
Після того козацька старшина
починає хитрістю забирати:
шантажем, погрозами починає
забирати землі, але козацька старшина
збільшувала свої земельні володіння ще
й за рахунок гетьманських нагороджень.
Тому що не завжди були гроші,
щоб заплатити за службу козакам
і гетьмани стосовно старшини
дуже часто розраховувалися землями.
За часів Мазепи склалася
така ситуація: землю мали всі -
хтось більше, хтось менше, селяни, міщани,
але найбільше землі
мала козацька старшина.
Отже, правдами і не правдами старшина
заволоділа величезною кількістю землі.
Та такою великою, що
сама обробити не могла.
Тоді вона звернулася
до бідних козаків і селян.
Запропонувавши поселитися на землях
старшини і за те, що вони отримали
із старшинської землі
невеличкий клаптик землі,
виконувати для старшини
невеликі повинності.
Так, сезонні роботи або
оплатити натуральний податок.
Спочатку все було добре і всі були
щасливі. Це називалося послушанієм.
В принципі, ні бідні козаки-сіромахи, ні
селяни-посполиті не противилися тому
і виконували послушаніє.
Але козацька старшина
хотіла бути впевненою,
що нічого з їхніми
робітниками не станеться,
землі будуть оброблені, а отже кожного
року їхня казна буде поповнюватися.
Через те, козацька старшина оці
послушанія поступово перетворює в панщину.
Панщина - це обов'язкове відпрацювання
протягом кількох днів на тиждень.
І уже у козаків і у селян, які мусили
виконувати панщину, не було ніякого вибору
Іван Мазепа не хоче
кривдити козацьку старшину,
бо на неї він планує опиратися
в своєму гетьмануванні.
Саме з козацької старшини
він прагне сформувати
аристократичну державницьку
таку еліту, особливий стан.
Але Іван Мазепа не хоче народних бунтів.
Це зашкодить його державі.
В такому випадку він
видає низку універсалів.
Найпоказовіше в тому, що він не відмінивши
панщину, обмежує кількість днів -
не чотири, як уже було
прийнято, а лише два.
Та панщина залишилась.
Іван Мазепа не дозволяє силою
перетворювати козаків на селян,
Іван Мазепа намагається
контролювати придбання нових земель.
Взагалі, в ті часи він не поступився
правом прийняття остаточного рішення
на володіння землею.
Жодна людина в Гетьманщині не могла
вважатися повноцінним господарем землі,
якщо вона не отримує письмовий
дозвіл гетьмана Івана Мазепи.
Тобто, врегулювавши земельні відносини
і в такий спосіб заспокоївши суспільство,
Іван Мазепа продовжує формувати
аристократичний суспільний стан.
Він дуже уважно придивляється
до козацької старшини.
Справа в тому, що козацька
старшина дуже амбіційна.
Кожен полковник мріє себе бачити
генеральною старшиною
або навіть гетьманом.
В той час ніхто не гребував писати
доноси, оббріхувати одне одного.
Тобто, ця старшина якийсь
час була ще ненадійною.
А отримавши, крім військових повноважень,
ще й адміністративні повноваження,
а перетворившись в великих,
багатих землевласників,
козацька старшина могла
взагалі вийти з-під влади Мазепи.
Тоді він придумав ще один
крок, він продовжив робити те,
що робили його попередники.
Але перед цим він звернувся в
думі до всієї козацької старшини,
а можливо навіть до всіх українців.
Мазепа не переставав нагадувати
про те, що в країні, в державі,
якщо вона хоче спокою і
розвитку - має бути один правитель.
І старшина мусила те визнати.
Не все відразу вдавалося,
але Мазепа робить ось що.
Щоб приручити чи
приборкати козацьку старшину,
він починає створювати
особливу козацьку еліту.
Раніше як люди ставали
козацькою старшиною? Пам'ятаєте?
Збирається козацька рада і
на козацькій раді обирають
полковників, сотників,
генеральну старшину.
Приходить час і наступна козацька
рада або продовжує повноваження,
або усуває від влади.
В принципі, люба людина
могла відчувати в собі можливість,
якщо заслужить того, стати на
якийсь час козацькою старшиною.
І старшина отримувала
привілеї тільки за те,
що виконувала старшинські зобов'язання.
Що робить Мазепа?
Він створює оцю козацьку еліту, але вже з
людей, яких не обирали на козацькій Раді.
Створюється таке собі бунчукове
товариство або значкове товариство.
Дуже дивні і незручні для
вас назви. А все дуже просто.
Частину людей, при тому що
хитрий Мазепа робить це дуже хитро,
він бере родичів козацької
старшини: братів, батьків, дядьків,
він бере під свою особисту
гетьманську опіку і свою гетьманську руку.
І називає їх бунчуковими товаришами.
Ніяких повноважень вони
не виконують особливих,
але вони отримують від гетьмана привілеї
і почувають себе особливими людьми.
Ви ж розумієте, що такі люди, які,
вважайте, нізащо отримали привілеї,
отримали свободу, права, вони
будуть вірою і правдою служити Мазепі,
бо як надав права, так і позбавить.
А з іншого боку, уявіть, як він круто
розправився з козацькою старшиною.
Як він приборкав козацьку старшину.
Козацька старшина, зазвичай,
могла готувати смуту проти гетьмана.
Але Мазепа повівся дуже мудро
і якщо він взяв під свою руку
родичів козацької старшини, то тим самим
він приборкав і саму козацьку старшину.
Навряд чи ти будеш затято
сперечатися з гетьманом.
Ти можеш його прогнівити, а
цей гнів виявиться не на тобі,
бо тебе обрали на козацькій Раді
та й «Коломацькі статті» забороняли
впливати якось на старшину особливо.
А от гнів Мазепи на родичах
старшинських запросто міг виявитися.
Через те й козацька старшина стала
потрохи, потрохи, але слухнянішою.
Кажуть так, що за Мазепи
настав довгоочікуваний спокій.
Інколи правління Мазепи в цей
час називають ще поруїнне правління.
Наш урок закінчений. Я б вам радила
знайти відповідний параграф у підручнику.
Прочитати відповідний матеріал,
познайомитися з питаннями
і знайти відповіді на них.
Я дякую вам за урок.
До наступних зустрічей.